HOLIDAY, TWEETING HAPPY
INDIGENOUS SURVIVORS DAY, F
THANKSGIVING.
OTHER ACTIVISTS ARE PUSHING THE
NAME THANKS TAKING AND GATHER AT
PLYMOUTH ROCK FOR NATIONAL DAY
OF MOURNING TO HIGHLIGHT THE
TREATMENT OF INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
ONE OF THESE FOLKS SAID HE WAS
LEAVING TWITTER AND CAME BACK TO
TWEET THAT.
>> Greg: AMAZING, SOMEBODY TOLD
ME YESTERDAY HE'S PLAYING A
MOVIE STAR AND THAT IS, I THINK
WRONG, ISN'T THAT CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION?
I CAN'T REMEMBER WHO.
I LOVE THE STORY, PERFECT SIM
BIOTIC RELATIONSHIP FOR HATERS
AND FOR US, HATERS CREATE CLICK
BAIT FOR WHINEY BLOCK POST OR
ARTICLES AND WE GET CONTENT FOR
A SLOW THANKSGIVING WEEK.
IT ISUN IF.
EVERYBODY WHO CELEBRATES
THANKSGIVING, THEY AREN'T DOING
IT FOR THE HISTORY, THEY ARE
DOING IT FOR THE FAMILY, MY
GUESS AND IT GOES BACK TO
WHATEVER HIS NAME IS, PEOPLE WHO
DO THIS STUFF, THEIR FAMILY HATE
THEM.
THEY CAN WRITE OFF THANKSGIVING,
NOBODY WANTS TO BE AROUND THEM,
RIGHT?
THEY THINK THAT EVERYBODY IS
DOING THIS FOR POLITICAL REASON,
I CELEBRATE THANKSGIVING BECAUSE
OF THE PILGRIMS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
PILGRIMS ARE TO BE HON EFTS WITH
YOU, WHAT ARE THEY?
>> WHO KNOWS.
>> Jessica: NOT MUCH ANYMORE.
>> THESE PEOPLE DON'T EAT THE
FOOD, THEY'RE VEGAN, THIS
HOLIDAY DOESN'T MATTER TO THEM.
HONESTLY ISSUE THE LEFT IS SO
NOT FUN ANYMORE, IT USED TO BE
YOU THROW THE BEST PARTIES,
GREAT TIME AND NOW LETTING THE
CRUSTY REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER.
>> PEOPLE STILL DO IT.
>> Jeanine: THE LEFT ARE NOT
MAKING SENSE ANYMORING, A
REPORTER SAID TEACH YOUR KIDS TO
EAT INSECTSES, THEY ARE SO UPSET
ABOUT EMISSIONS.
>> Greg: WHAT THEY HEARD,
CRICKETS.
>> Jeanine: MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THEY SAY GET RID OF COWS
ISSUE GET RID OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
OVER 70 BECAUSE OF EMISSION,
QUESTION OF WHEN THEY GET TO
YOU, THEY HATE EVERYTHING AND
EVERYONE AND THEY HATE THE
COUNTRY.
THANKSGIVING, NOTHING TO BE
THANKFUL FOR, REALLY?
>> MOVING FROM GREEN BEAN
CASSEROLE TO HATING THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
>> Greg: I HATE GREEN BEAN
CASSEROLE.
>> Jeanine: IT'S A SLIPPERY
SLOPE, THANK YOU.
>> I DON'T THINK THESE THINGS
ARE REAL, I GET IT, THIS WOMAN'S
NAME, REMEMBER THE POLITICO
EUROPE ARTICLE, THE EMISSIONS
TOLL OF THE WAR IN UKRAINE?
>> Jeanine: YEAH.
>> Dagen: EVERYONE IS GOING TO
KEEP FIGHTING THAT ARE WA, NO
MATTER WHAT LEVEL OF POLLUTANTS
COME OUT, IT IS CLICK BAIT, I
WOULD NEVER SAY IT IS SLOW NEWS
WEEK OR OUR PRODUCERS HAD US
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
MEANINGFUL.
FUN.
>> Greg: THAT IS HOW SLOW IT IS,
I HAD TO DO IT ON MY SHOW.
>> AND TONIGHT?
>> Greg: NO TWO DAYS IN A ROW.
>> HOW FUN LIBERALS ARE, GOOD
COMEDIANS ARE --
>> NOT TRUE.
>> THEY ARE LIBERTALIBERTARIANS.
>> Jeanine: GET THIS STRAIGHT.
>> Greg: BLOW OFF THE FIVE.
>> NO.
>> WHAT?
>> NO WONDER YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN
ON GREG'S SHOW.
>> Greg: SHE WAS GREAT, I
ENJOYED IT, NEVER AGAIN.
GUTFELD BANS JESSICA TARLOV IN
HEATED DISCUSSION.
>> WE LOVE JESSICA.
>> BEST MEAL FOR VEGETARIANS AND
VEGAN, EVERYTHING CAN BE, ALL
THE SIDES.
>> Greg: YOU'RE VEGAN.
>> NOT IN MY TEXAS HOUSEHOLD.
>> Jeanine: NOT IN MINE EITHER.
>> Greg: TURKEY IS GROSS, ISN'T
IT GROSS?
>> IT IS.
>> YOU EVER KILLED ONE?